et's go to our caller from the three 61 area
code. Who's calling today from three, six
one.
Hello?
Yes. Who's this?
Uh, this is Kyle from Texas. Hey Kyle. Uh,
I just wanted to say happy birthday or a belated
birthday and a fire. Your objectivity and
your work. It's really great. Um, I watched,
uh, Trump's state of the union last night
and uh, it was a very interesting, um, not,
not a very great thing at all. Um, he said
something about, uh, he was talking about,
um, the true Venezuelan president or something
like that at some point. And, um, that really
did, uh, uh, worry me. I, I wondered how this,
uh, how this could affect a decade of this
was, you know, another like, um, instance
of us interventionism or it was trying to,
trying to do something with this or what do
you think? Huh?
You know, it struck so, so first of all, as
I've said before, I do not think highly of
Nicolas Maduro. I think he's terrible. I think
he's raped and pillaged the resources of Venezuela
for his own gain. And he's completely corrupt.
But I, I can't have his replacement be selected
by the United States or the CIA or whatever.
Right. So you can hold both of you simultaneously.
The second that Donald Trump said, one Guido
is the rightful president of Venezuela and
we are completely behind him and Democrats
and Republicans both started cheering. That
is the worst of American intervention, you
know? And, and when you ask me why did he
do it, I feel like it's similar to when he
says we will never be a socialist country.
It's just sort of, it's, it's red meat that,
uh, may or may not relate to real policy,
but it's absolutely disastrous. And I cringed
when he did that.
Do you think that, um, uh, again, like Nicolas
Maduro or any of, you know, people that are
involved with them would see this and like
maybe, you know, say something to them. And
how do you think he would react?
Well, I don't think that Nicolas Maduro was
going to be having any conversation. You,
you're saying, would they say something to
Trump or to though,
no, it's so to, to, you know, say, uh, someone
who worked for Nicholas, you know, uh, watch
this or something like that, you know, who
keeps up with, you know, world politics or
something, just, you know, uh, and then, you
know, sees, you know, him saying something
about, you know, the true president, you know,
Venezuela. Do you think that, uh, this could
cause a very, um, passionate response?
I don't know. And of course, you know, the
Trump administration doesn't have diplomatic
relations with the Maduro administration.
So I don't, I don't really think that that's
the issue. I think it's more just, it's yet
again, you know, at least pretend like you're
not meddling. But once you publicly say this
guy is the rightful president of Venezuela,
then if that ends up becoming the reality
in Venezuela, it is understandably going to
be seen as a U S intervention in the United
States picking who they want. And that's the
last thing another Latin American country
needs.
Exactly. Yeah. All right. Well, uh, that,
that answered my question. Thank you.
Alright, appreciate the phone call. Thank
you so much. That does it for today. Sorry,
I was not able to get to everybody who called
in some great calls and we will take calls
again. Quick break back after this,